sticking with state specific legislation
let's go to Wyoming great you've done an
incredible job there walk us through
there's five pieces of legislation just
walk us through kind of what happened
and kind of where we are today and why
Wyoming has been able to kind of get the
stuff across the finish line well it was
just a fortuitous thing I was just
quietly because I happened to get into
Bitcoin pretty early had like a lot of
folks gains and was willing to share the
wealth and and also wanted to solve a
problem which is that there are not a
lot of female engineers and out there
not just in this industry but across the
board my dad had been department head of
Electrical Engineering for at the
University of Wyoming so I thought well
did this you know endowing with Bitcoin
gains of fund for female engineers a lot
of my boxes right and I just quietly did
it I wasn't telling anyone about it and
and
just assumed the University of Wyoming
could you know get an account with
coinbase I used to be on the Foundation
board there so I was you know helping
them through that and then ran smack-dab
into the piping la problem which was
that they had one of the worst money
transmission laws and was one of three
states coinbase couldn't do business in
and nor could they pay or circle and or
any of the other competitors and so I
said guys let's go fix that and it
turned into let's more than fix that
let's actually you know define utility
tokens as a new class of property
digital property that is exempt from
securities laws and from money
transmission laws and we exempted open
blockchain tokens from property taxes we
did all kinds of interesting things that
that basically made it a very crypto
friendly state it is the most crypto
friendly state right now absolutely and
so what do you think that does gonna
incentivize people to move to Wyoming
their business right in terms of to get
a lot of this work done there do you
think they can have an impact on other
states or at the federal level well
great question at Wyoming is the state
that invented the limited liability
company in 1977 so it wasn't actually
that far-fetched that it was going to be
doing some interesting things because it
has a history like Delaware of doing of
being a leader in a particular type of
business entity formation
and so we wanted to but but Delaware
stepped in and sort of stole Wyoming's
lead over the years as being the place
where most LLC's formed and so this was
a chance for Wyoming to try to steal
that lead back and and and you know it's
been it's been good a lot of folks have
have formed companies in Wyoming haven't
looked at the recent numbers but I I
just see it through the Wyoming go
octane coalition still everyday a couple
of companies reach out looking for
attorneys in Wyoming looking for
references for people who can help them
structure their their token offering you
ask the question about the federal
impact I there definitely are some
congressmen who are who watched what
happened in Wyoming and who very much
like what happened in Wyoming but the
federal issue is a whole new can of
worms and it's fascinating because
securities law is it has been
adjudicated by the supreme court to be a
federal jurisdiction but property is the
jurisdiction of the states so actually
in the next wyoming legislative session
the task force that i'm on we're gonna
have a couple of new bills and one of
them is going to actually pull out the
utility token language from the
securities title which is where it
resides right now in the in the chapter
if you will of Wyoming law that is
securities it's an exemption from
securities we're actually going to pull
it out and create it as a new class of
property that is for the legal minded
folks out there the Uniform Commercial
Code is state law commercial Commerce is
state law and so if we can actually get
it into a classification of property as
opposed to securities it actually
increases the probability that if there
ever is litigation that a judge is going
to say that's not federal jurisdiction
so we're setting it up for folks to to
come in who want to stay in the United
States but recognize that there's
there's legal risk up certainly not
advising folks to do anything without
getting independent counsel I'm not
giving legal or investment advice here
but but we have had a number of
companies who have very publicly said
they want to stay in the United States
and they're coming to Wyoming because
they just don't believe that the federal
government should be running American
businesses offshore